[Music]
hi it's Michele from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry PhD and lover of
retinoids rationalize are vitamin A
derivatives they are some of the most
popular skincare ingredients and their
effectiveness is backed by a lot of
studies but like everything else in
skincare beauty there are lots of myths
and half-truths about how they work and
how you're meant to use them so today
we're going to be talking about some of
these myths and we're going to bust them
if you like hearing about the science
behind beauty products you can give this
video a thumbs up subscribe to my
channel and click the notification bell
so you don't miss any videos what is a
retinoid rationale its are ingredients
that work like vitamin A they have lots
and lots of applications in skincare
their main uses are to help with acne
and to help with aging so things like
wrinkles and pigmentation they're one of
the few things that can reverse the
signs of aging some examples of
retinoids are rational threatenin as
Darlene teaser routine retinol esters
and retinaldehyde let's start with the
first myth
retinoids will thin your skin this is
actually one of the myths that stopped
me from trying retinoids for a really
long time rationals will thin one
specific layer of skin but overall they
will actually thicken it they thicken
the Living layer so the dermis and the
epidermis above it but they thin down or
compact the stratum corneum so on my
handi skin model they will thicken all
of these layers the epidermis up here
and the dermis down here but they will
compact this layer the stratum corneum
which is made up of dead cells so the
way that retinol is thickened epidermis
is that it causes it to proliferate in
other words produce more cells
retinoids also increase the production
of glycosaminoglycans
or GA g's these are long sugar-based
molecules that can hold on to lots of
water there like a humectant moisturizer
within your skin one example is
hyaluronic acid this means that with
this extra water retention it plumps up
your skin retinoids also prevent
collagen degradation and increase its
product
and so that means that you will get a
thick of dermis rusher allas can also
compact the stratum corneum which is
generally a good thing when you have a
thinner stratum corneum this is the dead
cells on the surface of the skin this
actually makes your skin look glowy and
smoother but thinning the stratum
corneum can also have negative effects
the stratum corneum is there to protect
the living layers of your skin and so if
it gets too thin it can lead to
sensitive skin the thickening of the
lower layers is actually what helps give
retinoids their anti-aging effect if you
have plumper skin then it looks smoother
and wrinkles are less deep rational its
are light sensitive so you need to use
them in the dark
this is partly true a lot of retinoid
ingredients are unstable in light and so
if you have too much light exposure they
break down which means they will no
longer work this is especially the case
with sunlight sunlight is one of the
most intense sources of light that we
get but there are some retro noise that
aren't light-sensitive so for example
some of the newer ones like adapt lean
and teaser teens they aren't light
sensitive so you can actually use them
during the day and it says this on the
packet threatenin is generally light
sensitive but it can be formulated so
that it isn't micronized stretching on
for example is photo stable which means
that it is not sensitive to light
exposure retinol is generally unstable
and so it breaks down in light which
means that you should be applying it at
night if you're not sure whether your
particular retinoid product is photo
stable look at the packaging and do
whatever the instructions tell you to do
if you don't see immediate results with
your rationale and you should give up
this is not true for skincare products
in general and it is especially not true
for rationals some people will see
immediate results but a lot of people
will not and that doesn't mean that the
retinoid isn't working unlike a lot of
other skincare products
retinoids can have effects deeper in the
skin and to get there and have these
effects it can take a bit longer so you
should be using rationalize for a longer
time before dismissing them as something
that doesn't work for you they work on a
longer timeframe than most other
ingredients so a good rule of thumb is
give it three to six months before you
decide it's not for you rationale it's
can't give immediate results on the flip
side some people say that retinoids
cannot possibly give you immediate
results and anything that you see early
on is either just in your head or
because of some other products that
you're using but rash mites have been
documented to give some people very
quick results in peer-reviewed studies
the fastest results are that your skin
might look smoother and you get a pink
or rosy glow but note that this doesn't
happen with everyone which i think is
one of the reasons this myth exists some
other reasons for this myth is that most
trials on retinoids lasts longer but
just because they didn't measure the
results earlier doesn't mean that they
didn't exist there's also the fact that
skin tone over attempts to take a while
and so some results won't be immediately
visible but there are some effects of
retinoids that don't require skin
turnover to see this is especially the
changes that take place on the shallower
layers of your skin so for example the
compaction of the stratum corneum
happens quite quickly the changes in the
upper epidermis also are very fast
results that require changes deeper in
the skin so things like reduction of
deep wrinkles or reduction of
pigmentation these will take a bit
longer so again these early results
don't happen for everyone and if you
don't have early results it doesn't
necessarily mean that you won't have
results later on in one study with
threatenin five to ten percent of people
saw changes within two weeks about half
of the people saw changes within a month
and almost everyone had changes within
12 weeks
don't use retinoids until you see signs
of aging this myth is not true for a few
reasons there is no evidence that using
rationalist early
using them long-term will cause any sort
of skin damage the changes in your skin
that lead to skin aging will occur
before you can actually see any signs of
aging on your skin so retinoids can stop
and help reverse these microscopic
science before they start showing up
retinoids are also useful for things
other than anti-aging the other thing
that retinoids are good for is acne
resinize help with skin turnover and it
reduces the tiny microscopic clogs or
micro coma dough's that happen in your
skin before you start getting pimples
you also won't run out of skin because
your skin is turning over to fuss this
is not how skin works so there is no
limit on how old you have to be before
you can start using retinoids but
Cuchillo is better than rationale I've
actually even seen someone say that the
Cuchillo is better than prescription
threatenin which is classified as a drug
BQ chill is an ingredient that's found
in the bad Chi plant there's been a lot
of hype about how it is a natural
rational or that it's better than
rational or it's just as good as retinol
without any of the downsides this is
pretty far-fetched there's been one
recent independent clinical study that's
open access which is pretty impressive
it was a 12-week trial where 44 people
applied either naught point five percent
of rationale once a day or Northland 5%
per Cuchillo twice a day on their skin
at the end of the study they found that
bql and rationale reduce wrinkles and
hyperpigmentation around the same amount
but people using retinol have more
peeling and stinging while people use in
Baku chill have more redness the hype
also partly comes from the fact that
Baku children all have some similarities
in how they work on a microscopic level
but the big difference is firstly bakuto
had to be used twice a day whereas
retinol was used once a day there's also
nowhere near the same amount of evidence
for pqc all compared to retinoids so
Baku chill is a promising ingredient but
it doesn't really belong in the
conversation about rash nights you need
to use recognized daily to have any
effect
this is not true there's been studies
where treasure Nome was used once a week
or three times a week or every second
day and they found that their worst
improvements in skin most of these
studies were done on threatenin which is
a particularly strong prescription only
rationale and this is the case with most
studies on retinoids there's lots of
data and threatenin but not much on
other retinoids but there's no reason
why this doesn't apply to other records
as well so these are the top myths on
retinoids if you have any other myths
that you've been wondering about leave
them in the comments if you want to get
started on brat remorse you can check
out my video on how to introduce them
slowly you'll also want to have a gentle
cleanser and a moisturizer and a
sunscreen already in your routine for
more on this you can check out my ebook
the lab muffin guide to basic skincare
if you think that retinoids sound a bit
through hard call for you right now you
might want to try some exfoliants first
i have a free downloadable guide to
exfoliation and the links to all of
these resources I in the description I
hope you enjoyed this video if you did
give it a thumbs up you can subscribe to
my channel as well you can also follow
me on Instagram and check out my blog
for more beauty science
giveme video topic suggestions in the
comments as well and I will see you next
time